[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
MATTHEW VANDER
HEIDEN: So today we're
going to begin by going
over the Calvin cycle, which
I know I went quite
quickly on just
to introduce it at the
end of the last lecture.
And so we'll spend a
little time there first.
And then we'll
move on to discuss
the main topic of today,
which is the pentose phosphate
pathway.
But before we get
there, I just want
to remind you about the Calvin
cycle, which you'll recall
happened in three phases.
So there was the
fixation, reduction,
and regeneration phases.
And so remember, fixation was
this special reaction that
occurs only in photosynthetic
organisms catalyzed by rubisco
ribulose-1,5-bisphosphate
carboxylase/oxygenase,
where a
ribulose-1,5-bisphosphate
molecule combines with CO2,
and then is split to produce
2,3-phosphoglycerates.
This was the reaction
that Calvin described
as the dark reaction, that
now bears the name of this
as the Calvin cycle.
Once you get those
2,3-phosphoglycerates,
you can then enter them
into gluconeogenesis.
This, of course,
happens in the stroma
of the chloroplast in eukaryotic
photosynthetic organisms,
and it's exactly the reactions
for the reduction phase
that we learned about for
glycolysis or gluconeogenesis
when we described it at the
beginning of the course.
And so that 3PG is turned into
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphates and
dihydroxyacetone phosphate.
Of course, that
has to go backwards
through the phosphoglycerate
kinase as well
as the glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate dehydrogenase step
that we learned about
when we discussed
glycolysis and gluconeogenesis.
And so therefore, our cost ATP,
as well as need a source of
electrons to go through
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
dehydrogenase, and that
those come from NADPH
when this is occurring in
photosynthetic organisms
and the chloroplast.
Once you get these
trioses, of course,
you can continue
with gluconeogenesis,
combine them at the aldolase
step to make fructose
1,6-bisphosphate.
That can be-- take the
phosphate off by FPPase
to give you fructose
6-phosphate.
That can then be isomerized
to glucose 6-phosphate, which,
of course, could be further--
remove the phosphate
and go to glucose,
or be turned into glucose
1-phosphate or whatever else
to build starch or another
storage sugar for the plant--
combine glucose and
a fructose, say,
to make sucrose, table sugar.
And so dose reduction steps
we didn't spend a lot of time
on, because it's really
gluconeogenesis with the use
of NADPH rather than
NADH, as we described it
when we describe
gluconeogenesis back
at the early part of the course.
Now, once you run this part
of the cycle that, of course,
gives you glucose.
But of course, in order to
net run this as a cycle,
much like we saw
for the TCA cycle,
that if this is going
to run as a cycle,
you need a source of carbon
acceptors for the next CO2.
Anaplerosis, that we
described in the TCA cycle--
remember, we needed a
source of oxaloacetate
that could net accept
the next acytal-CoA
to continue running the cycle.
Same thing happens here.
You need a source of
ribulose-1,5-bisphosphate
so rubisco has
something to add CO2 to.
And so anaplerosis of this
cycle involves regeneration
of ribulose-1,5-bisphosphate.
And that's the confusing
set of reactions
that I introduced
last time that we'll
spend much more time
talking about today.
And so, effectively, this
comes from both 6 and 3 carbon
units-- so glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate and fructose
6-phosphate with a series of
2- and 3-carbon swaps that
ultimately generate these three
pentoses, xylulose 5-phosphate,
ribose 5-phosphate, and
another xylulose 5-phosphate.
Once you have those
xylulose 5-phosphate,
you can see differs from
ribulose-1,5-bisphosphate
by the stereochemistry
at the three position.
And so an epimerase
reaction can fix that.
We talked about those earlier.
And then, of course, you need to
phosphorylation the 1 position
on the sugar to give you
ribulose-1,5-bisphosphate.
That's how you deal with
the 2 xylulose 5-phosphates.
And ribose
5-phosphate, of course,
you need to change it from
the aldose to the ketose.
So that's an isomerase reaction
plus a phosphorylation to give
you ribulose-1,5-bisphosphate.
Now, if you run
this entire cycle,
if you're going to net
generate a hexose--
a glucose or some other hexose--
for the plant to store
as a storage sugar--
of course, if it's
coming from CO2,
you need to run
the cycle six times
to take six CO2s and net
generate one hexose that
can be stored for later.
And so I just want to
start by showing you
that this accounting can work.
So if we start here
at the top with six
ribulose-1,5-bisphosphates
and add 6 CO2 molecules,
you're going to net generate
12 3-phosphoglycerates.
Those 12 3-phosphoglycerates
can be turned into, of course,
12 glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate.
So that's going to cost 12 ATPs.
And 12 is from the light
reactions and photosynthesis.
And so now you have 12
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphates.
I'm going to divide them
up in the following way.
If I take two of those
and place them over here,
then take the remaining
10, use five of those
here and turn five more into
dihydroxyacetone phosphate--
so that gives me 5 plus
5 plus 2 equals 12 total.
Of these five glyceraldehyde
3-phosphates and five
dihydroxyacetone phosphates,
I can run them through
the aldolase step to
generate five fructose
1,6-bisphosphates, turn those
five fructose 1,6-bisphosphates
into five fructose 6-phosphates.
And, of course, I
need one of those
to ultimately generate a
glucose 6-phosphate or whatever
hexose that I'm going to
have as my net product.
If I do that, that
leaves me four left over.
And so I'm going to
allocate them such
that I have two
here and two here.
So the two I have here can be
combined with the remaining two
glyceraldehyde
3-phosphates to generate
two xylulose
5-phosphates and two
erythrose 4-phosphates,
a 5-carbon sugar,
and a 4-carbon sugar.
This 5-carbon sugar-- this
xylulose 5-phosphate--
I can then use a
epimerase and ATP.
So that's two ATPs
running back through.
And that's going to net give me
two ribulose-1,5-bisphosphates,
which I'll draw up there later.
Coming back down here, I
have this two erythrose
4-phosphates and two
fructose 6-phosphates.
So this was a two carbon swap.
So I took the two
carbons for this step
to generate the xylulose
5-phosphate and erythrose
4-phosphate.
I took two carbons from
fructose 6-phosphate
added them to
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate.
That's how I got the 5-carbon
xylulose 5-phosphate.
And that left me with a
4-carbon erythrose 4-phosphate.
So all the carbons add up.
Now I take this 4-carbon
erythrose 4-phosphate
and the two remaining
fructose 6-phosphates.
And if I move three
carbons from here
to there, what I end up getting
is a 7-carbon sedoheptulose
7-phosphate and a 3-carbon
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate.
And so two in, two out--
now I'm going to move two
carbons again-- to carbons
from sedoheptulose
7-phosphate to
the glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate.
And that's going to give me 2.
7 minus 2 is 5.
3 plus 2 is 5.
So two 5-carbon sugars,
two ribose 5-phosphates,
and two xylulose 5-phosphates--
xylulose 5-phosphates
through the epimerase,
costing me two ATP.
Ribose 5-phosphate through
isomerase, costing me two ATP.
And when I net generate is two
ribulose 5-phosphates here,
two ribulose
5-phosphates there, two
ribulose 5-phosphates there.
2 plus 2 plus 2 equals 6.
And so by running
this cycle six times,
six ribulose-1,5-bisphosphate
in, six CO2 in, six
ribulose-1,5-bisphosphate
out, and one hexose out.
So all the accounting adds up.
I know there's a lot
of moving pieces there.
It's confusing.
But we'll see as we go through
today why it works this way.
However, before we
get there, I just
want to stress what we've
actually accomplished here.
So basically, we started
with six CO2 molecules.
And we added to that 12 NADPHs.
And so those 12
NADPHs came there
through the
3-phosphoglycerate to generate
the glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate-- so running
through the GAPDH
reaction using NADPH.
And so we had to
do that 12 times
plus a total of
18 ATP molecules.
And so 12 of them up there
through the phosphoglycerate
kinase cost me 12 ATPs, plus I
needed an additional six ATPs
to regenerate the
ribulose-1,5-bisphosphates
re-phosphorylation the six
pentoses that I generated
through the regeneration
phase of the Calvin cycle.
And so that's 12 plus 2 plus 2
plus 2, or 12 plus 6 equals 18.
And what I net generate
is one glucose molecule
from my six CO2.
And, of course, to do this, I
needed a lot of energy input.
That comes from the 12 NADPHs
and the 18 ATPs, which,
of course, are the products
of the light reactions
of photosynthesis.
And so you'll recall that if
we go back to our chloroplast,
the light reactions
are happening here
at the thylakoid membranes
of the chloroplast.
And that's where
we're generating
our ATP and our NADPH
from the light reactions.
And then here in the
stroma of the chloroplast
is where we're doing the dark
reactions, and so perfectly
positioned where the
ATP and from the light
reactions are there to
fuel the dark reactions,
the Calvin cycle, and
net have this turn CO2
and generate a pentose--
glucose, fructose, combine
them to make a sucrose,
or a bunch of glucose that we
can build as alpha-1,4 polymers
to make starch, depending on
the organism and how it chooses
to store its sugars.
So that is the Calvin cycle.
But what I want to do now
is look a bit more closely
on why it works
this way-- that is,
why nature chose this confusing
system with two and three
carbon swaps.
Wouldn't it just have
been easier to just,
I don't know, take CO2s
and build a glucose
molecule together?
Well of course,
the reason it does
this has to do with
the chemistry of how
the reactions happen.
And if we look more closely
at the various steps and these
swaps that take place in
the regeneration phase,
basically what we see is
in every single situation--
so it's basically this
reaction, this reaction,
and this reaction, which are the
swap part of the regeneration
phase--
you see that in every case,
we're moving two carbons.
And so here two
carbons were removed
from fructose 6-phosphate to
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate.
So 6 minus 2 equals 4.
3 plus 2 equals 5.
That's how we get
erythrose 4-phosphate
and xylulose 5-phosphate.
Here we started with
our fructose 6-phosphate
and our erythrose 4-- phosphate,
moved three carbons from here
to there.
So 6 minus 3 equals 3.
4 plus 3 equals 7.
So that's a three carbon swap.
And then here, again, is
another two carbon swap--
so three carbon glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate, 7-carbon
sedoheptulose 7-phosphate.
Move two carbons
from here to there.
7 minus 2 is 5.
3 plus 2 is 5.
And that's how we get
those two pentoses.
Now, if we look more
closely at this,
what you'll see in
every case, the swap
involves a ketose and an aldose.
So here we have
fructose 6-phosphate.
It's a ketose.
Here we have
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate.
It's an aldose.
And what we end up
with is the aldose
getting longer by
two carbons to become
a ketose and the ketose
getting shorter by two carbons
to become an aldose.
Same thing happens here--
here we have a
ketose and an aldose.
We do the swap.
We have the aldose getting
longer by 3 carbons
to become a ketose,
and the ketose becoming
shorter three carbons, in this
case, to become an aldose.
And lastly, same swap
we showed before--
here we have a
ketose and an aldose.
The ketose gets shorter by two
carbons to become an aldose.
And the aldose gets longer by
two carbons to become a ketose.
So I recognize
that it's very hard
to follow that when I'm saying
aldose and ketose over and over
and over again.
But effectively in every single
case, what we're doing is
we're moving two
carbons or three carbons
and we're moving them from
a ketose to an aldose.
And so that means that our
product, when we do that,
is we end up getting
a longer ketose.
So our former aldose
plus 2 or plus 3 carbons
becomes a longer ketose.
And then we end up
getting a shorter aldose
from the former ketose minus
two or minus three carbons.
So if you go and
look at that, you
will see in every
single case where
we're doing those two
and three carbon swaps,
we're effectively
following that rule.
So these reactions, which
I've abbreviated up there,
are catalyzed by
enzymes called TK,
which stands for
transketolase or TA,
which stands for transaldolase--
TK, transketolase,
TA, transaldolase.
I want to point out that
these are the enzymes that
catalyze the transketolase
is going to catalyze the two
carbon swaps.
And the transaldolase is going
to catalyze the three carbon
swaps.
And so twice we
used transketolase,
once we used transaldolase.
Transketolase moved the
two carbons from the ketose
to the aldose, giving you a
longer ketose and a shorter
aldose.
And transaldolase
also catalyzed,
in this case, the
3-carbon swap, giving you
a longer ketose and a
shorter aldose following
the exact same rules.
Now, these enzymes is
why it works this way.
And I want to point out that the
enzyme names are absolutely not
helpful for remembering
what they do.
Both enzymes use a ketose
donor and an aldose acceptor.
Both generate products
where the former aldose
becomes longer as a ketose
and the former ketose
becomes shorter as an aldose.
So don't rely on the enzyme
names to remember what they do.
You'll see partially
why they're named
what they are as we go
through the mechanisms.
But for now, just remember that
transketolase, two carbons,
transaldolase, three carbons--
different numbers of carbons
moved, but always follow
the exact same rules.
I know this is confusing
and so it's probably better
to go through
exactly what is going
on using a couple examples.
So let's start off
here with a ketose.
So here is a ketose.
This is, of course,
fructose 6-phosphate.
And so fructose
6-phosphate is a ketose.
If we use this step
here as an example--
fructose 6-phosphate and
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate--
so here we start
with our ketose.
And if we also use
with it a aldose--
so here is glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate,
which is, of course, an aldose.
So if we subject this to a
transketolase reaction, which,
remember, moving
two carbons, we're
going to take the two
carbons from the ketose
and move them to the aldose.
So if we do that, what
we end up with is--
if we take two
carbons from here,
we end up with a shorter aldose.
And we end up with
a longer ketose.
So transketolase reaction--
ketose donor of two carbons,
give them to an aldose,
acceptor of two carbons.
That gives me an
aldose that's shorter--
minus 2 carbons.
So the bottom four carbons
from fructose 6-phosphate
now become a erythrose
4-phosphate, an aldose.
And here we have our aldose
accepts the two carbons.
And so now we generate a ketose
that is longer by two carbons.
And that gives me
this longer ketose--
so in this case,
xylulose 5-phosphate.
So this is the exact
transketolase reaction
that is right there--
this first part,
fructose 6-phosphate
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
give me an erythrose 4-phosphate
and a xylulose 5-phosphate.
So two carbons move from
a ketose to an aldose,
gives me a shorter aldose
and a longer ketose.
Now, if we do exactly
the same thing,
but this time rather than
do a transketolase reaction,
do a transaldolase
reaction-- so now
I'm going to move three carbons.
So same thing-- ketose
donor, aldose acceptor.
So now I'm going to end up
with-- if I donate three
carbons from that
ketose, what I end up
with is 3 carbons remaining.
And if I start with this
3-carbon as an acceptor,
move three carbons over, now
I end up with a longer ketose.
So instead do a
transaldolase reaction--
take three carbons
from the ketose,
transfer them to the aldose.
That means the ketose now
gets shorter by three carbons
and becomes an aldose.
And the former aldose gets
longer by three carbons
and becomes a ketose.
And so if I use these two
things as substrate-- fructose
6-phosphate and those are
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate,
what do I generate?
I generate another
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate and
fructose 6-phosphate,
where all I do
is scramble which
carbons are aware.
And so this, obviously,
is not a reaction
I showed for how you do
anaplerosis of the Calvin
cycle, but clearly can happen.
These transketolase and
transaldolase enzymes
are highly reversible.
And so this is, of course, is
happening-- scrambling carbons
around, but there's no net
generation or consumption
of anything, because,
of course, we're
just moving carbons between
a ketose and an aldose,
generating the same ketose
and the same aldose using
these particular substrates.
But if we look at how it worked
where we showed it here--
fructose 6-phosphate
erythrose 4-phosphate--
we end up moving
those three carbons
onto erythrose 4-phosphate.
That gives us
sedoheptulose 7-phosphate
and leaves us with
a shorter aldose
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate.
And so I color-coded
the carbons here
to show how transketolase
and transaldolase work.
And if you go back over here
through the Calvin cycle,
you will note that every single
one of the reactions where
I drew transketolase
and transaldolase
follows those exact rules.
So why does it work this way?
Well, it works this way
because of how transketolase
and transaldolase
work as enzymes.
And so as I said at the
beginning of the course
and have now alluded
to several times,
is that biochemistry is
just nature repurposing
the same chemistries,
the same reactions,
with slight variations
over and over
and over again to
build that complexity.
And I think that is
very evident here.
So a lot of complexity in what
we described, but it's really
just using two
enzymes-- transketolase
and transaldolase.
And transketolase and
transaldolase basically
use variations on chemistry
that we've already
seen to catalyze
these reactions, which
is almost certainly why
it evolved this way,
because you already
have a reaction that
catalyzes something.
You tweak it.
And now you can get these
swaps and nature figures
out a way to have it work.
And so what are those reactions?
So transketolase,
which, remember,
catalyzes the 2-carbon movement.
That's two carbons
that are moving.
It uses TPP+.
So that's, remember,
thiamine pyrophosphate.
We saw it before.
It was involved in those
decarbonization reactions
of alpha-keto acids.
We saw it in the pyruvate
dehydrogenase reaction
to turn pyruvate
into acetyl-CoA.
We saw it in ethanol
metabolism to turn pyruvate
into acetaldehyde.
And we saw it in the TCA cycle
to turn alpha-ketogluterate
into succinate.
And in all of those
cases, we decarboxylated--
that is broke a carbon-carbon
bond of an alpha-ketoacid.
And that used TPP+.
And basically what happens in
the transketolase reaction is
TPP+ plus is also used to
break a carbon-carbon bond.
But this time, rather
than releasing CO2,
it's basically moving
the 2-carbon unit over
to another molecule, as
I'll show in a minute.
Transaldolase, which,
remember, moves three carbons,
does not use TPP+.
Instead, it uses an
aldolase-like mechanism
to move the three carbons.
And so aldolase, you remember,
if you think way back to when
we described glycolysis,
aldolase broke
the carbon-carbon bond
to take you from fructose
1,6-bisphosphate to
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
and dihydroxyacetone phosphate.
And so that was done with
an active site lysine.
And transaldolase
basically repurposed
that reaction-- also has
an active site lysine,
breaks a carbon-carbon
bond, but this time
to transfer the 3-carbon
unit from ketose donor
to an aldose acceptor.
And when we go
through the mechanism,
you'll see it will be
very reminiscent of,
if you look back
in your notes, how
aldolase worked in glycolysis.
So let's start with the
mechanism of transketolase.
So transit delays uses
thiamine pyrophosphate.
So remember this here
is the active part
of thiamine pyrophosphate,
the stabilized carbanion.
So let's here just draw
a generic ketose donor.
So this intermediate
is very similar to what
we saw for the--
when we did decarboxilation
of the alpha-ketoacid.
Basically, this same
mechanism would occur.
But rather than
release CO2, which gets
released here instead
is this shorter aldose
with two carbons that
are lost and remain here
on the active site of the enzyme
on thiamine pyrophosphate.
Now, this molecule here then
needs to be transferred to a--
so here we have our
aldose acceptor.
So that then will
regenerate TPP+.
And, of course,
what we're left with
is our former aldose, which
now becomes a ketose that's
two carbons longer.
And so ketose donor, TPP+
breaks off the two carbons,
releases that ketose two
carbons shorter as an aldose.
Those two carbons
are then transferred
to an aldose acceptor.
And it becomes two carbons
longer and becomes a ketose.
And so the net
result is is that we
take two carbons
from the ketose donor
give them to the
aldose acceptor.
The ketose gets
shorter by two carbons
to become a shorter aldose.
And the former aldose acceptor
gets longer by two carbons
to become a ketose.
And this is, basically,
repurposing very similar
chemistry to what we saw
for the decarbonization
of alpha-ketoacids.
So that's how
transketolase works.
This is how transaldolase works.
And so this works to move,
of course, three carbons.
And so this is going
to work much more
like what we saw for
the aldolase reaction
in glycolysis.
So let's here use this here
as our generic ketose donor.
So this is going to be a
donor of three carbons--
so active site lysine
and transaldolase place.
So basically, this should
look very familiar to you
as the mechanism for how
aldolase worked to break
the carbon-carbon bond to divide
fructose 1,6-bisphosphonate
to glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
and dihydroxyacetone phosphate,
except, in this case, what we're
left with is taking this ketose
donor.
And it releases an aldose
that's three carbons shorter
while retaining, down
to the enzyme, the three
carbons from the ketose
donor, just like we
saw for the aldolase reaction.
Now, when we saw the
aldolase reaction--
glycolysis, of course-- we just
took this off the molecule.
And that's how we ended up
with glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
from the bottom and
dihydroxyacetone on the top.
The difference here
is is now we're
going to use this
as a way to combine
it, move this 3-carbon unit
rather than just releasing it,
transferred over to
an aldose acceptor.
And then, once we re-take
the 3-carbon unit and add it
to the aldose acceptor, you'll
see that then you release this,
now, aldose three carbons
longer as a ketose--
again, very similar mechanism,
if you look back on your notes,
to how aldolase
worked in glycolysis.
And so the net effective
the transaldolase reaction
is that we take three
carbons from a ketose donor.
We end up releasing an aldose
that's three carbons shorter,
take those three
carbons, transfer them
to an aldose acceptor,
and now generate a ketose
that is three carbons longer.
And so this ultimately
moves to carbon units
in the case of transketolase,
three carbon units
in the case of transaldolase.
It evolved this way because it's
repurposing existing chemistry
to allow these two and
three carbon swaps.
That ultimately gives
you the flexibility
to build a cycle like
the Calvin cycle, where
one can interconvert 3-carbon
sugars and 6-carbon sugars
with 5-carbon sugars and
ultimately make that cycle
work.
And so on the Calvin cycle this
is useful because we can start
with the 5-carbon
ribulose-1,5-bisphosphate
and net generate a hexose
as a storage sugar,
while regenerating our 5-carbon
ribulose-1,5-bisphosphate.
But it has an additional benefit
in that this is also a way
to generate 5-carbon sugars.
And so you can see
that ribose 5-phosphate
is one of the intermediates
in the carbon cycle.
And, of course, ribose
is a useful sugar
to generate nucleoside.
So all the time you spent
talking about RNA and DNA
with Professor
Yaffe, you saw lots
of 5-carbon sugars,
lots of pentoses,
as the ribose in
those backbones.
And so it's not just-- you
know now, not just nucleosides.
It's also part of
lots of cofactors--
NAD, FAD, coenzyme A.
All of those cofactors
ended up having
nucleosides in them--
and so lots of ribose
needed by the cell
in order to make nucleosides.
And this is a way to, for at
least photosynthetic organisms,
the Calvin cycle, a way for
them to make ribose to generate
all those nucleosides.
Now, that's great if you're
a photosynthetic organism,
because you can run the Calvin
cycle and do it in a way
that you can store carbon
for the night as some hexose
that you can burn
later when you don't
have light to carry
out the light reactions
of photosynthesis.
Or, if you want to
grow, you can use
it to make nucleosides
and replicate your genome,
or make RNA, or make ribosomes.
And in fact, the Calvin
cycle generating ribose
is a way to get those.
You'll see when we get
to this in a few lectures
that ribose 5-phosphate
is the starting point
to generate both purine
and pyrimidine nucleotides.
However, this reactions,
the Calvin cycle,
is unique to
photosynthetic organisms.
But of course animals,
including us-- are all
nonphotosynthetic organisms--
also need to make ribose.
And we also need a
way to make NADPH.
And we need a source of
NADPH for the same reason
plants needed it.
And that is we need something to
have an NADPH/NADP ratio that's
useful to keep our
glutathione reduced.
That allows us to keep our
cells in a reducing state,
battle reactive
oxygen species, help
with reductive biosynthesis.
We all know that if
we eat too much food,
we can all store those
excess calories as fat.
Fat is reduced carbon.
Making their reduced
carbon in the fatty acids
is going to require a
source of electrons.
All organisms, that
source of electrons
is going to be NADPH,
which makes sense,
because an NADPH/NADP
ratio that's more reduced
can favor reduction reactions.
And in our next
lecture, we will see
how that's used to actually
store carbon as fat when
there's excess NADPH around.
Now, that makes a lot of sense.
But obviously, as
nonphotosynthetic organisms,
we, as well as all non
photosynthetic organisms,
can't rely on photosynthesis
in the Calvin cycle.
And so we need
another pathway that
allows us to do both
NADPH production as well
as ribose production.
And that's where we get to
the pentose phosphate pathway.
And so the pentose
phosphate pathway, the PPP--
also sometimes referred to as
the pentose phosphate shunt--
is a major pathway
that all organisms,
photosynthetic and
nonphotosynthetic,
can use to generate NADPH,
which is useful for cells
as a source of reducing power,
as well as ribose, which
is going to be
necessary if we're
going to build nucleosides
and cofactors that
contain nucleosides sites.
Now, how one runs the pentose
phosphate pathway to get
these two products is
conceptually akin to the Calvin
cycle.
But it's a Calvin
cycle in reverse.
And so if we look at what really
happens in the Calvin cycle,
we start with a 5-carbon
sugar, we add CO2,
we reduce it with NADPH
and ATP, and we end up
generating a 6-carbon sugar.
And so the pentose
phosphate pathway
is we're going to start
with a 6-carbon sugar.
We're going to
oxidize to generate
CO2 and a 5-carbon sugar.
And if we oxidize, we're going
to end up-- those electrons
have to go somewhere.
And so we can put
those electrons and net
generate NADPH.
The Calvin cycle is, of
course, doing reduction.
Remember, reduced carbon
is energy storage.
Oxidizing carbon
is energy release.
And so the Calvin cycle,
we had to put energy in.
That energy, of course,
came from photosynthesis.
That's the magic of us
harvesting energy from the sun
in order to do biology.
And so the light
products, the NADPH
came from
photosynthesis in order
to net run the Calvin cycle.
But just like we saw with
glycolysis and gluconeogensis,
if one direction of a pathway
requires energy input,
well the other direction
is going to be favorable.
And so if we oxidize
a 6-carbon sugar
to make a 5-carbon
sugar and CO2,
that intuitively, hopefully
by now, should be favorable.
And so we can use
that energy release
to charge up an NADPH to NDP
ratio that now gives the cell
a source of reducing power--
so energetically makes sense.
Now, this pentose
phosphate pathway
is also sometimes
called a shunt,
because really
the way this works
is as a branch of glycolysis--
a shunt of glycolysis,
if you will, because
it's an alternative way
to run glycolysis and get NADPH.
And so the glucose
6-phosphate-- remember,
for glycolysis we
can isomerize to give
us fructose 6-phosphate.
And then ultimately
in glycolysis,
we can generate glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate down to pyruvate,
which can go to TCA cycle, et
cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
Of course, glucose
is a 6-carbon sugar.
Fructose is a 6-carbon sugar.
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
is a 3-carbon sugar--
aldose, ketose, aldose.
So if we take our
glucose 6-phosphate
and we send it into
the pentose phosphate
pathway, the pentose
phosphate shunt,
and rather than
oxidize the glucose
as we did in
glycolysis, we oxidize
it to release CO2 and
generate a 5-carbon sugar,
like a ribose 5-phosphate.
Now we have a way to get
5-carbon sugars pentoses
by oxidizing
glucose 6-phosphate.
Those electrons have
to go somewhere.
And so that ends up being
a way to generate NADPH.
Once we get those
5-carbon sugars,
that's great if we want
to build nucleotides.
But it turns out
we could also run
a bunch of transketolase
and transaldolase reactions
and interconvert 5-carbon
sugars with 6-carbon sugars
and 3-carbon sugars, just as
we did in the Calvin cycle.
And if we run it
this way, you can
see that I can now
make this effectively
an alternative version
of glycolysis--
a shunt, if you will.
Start with glucose
6-phosphate rather than
going the traditional way.
First, go to make
5-carbon sugars
and then bring those
carbons back into glycolysis
that I can then further
oxidize to pyruvate
and oxidize in the
TCA cycle, et cetera.
And so all of this--
so glycolysis happens
and the cytosol, the
pentose phosphate
pathway happens in the cytosol.
And really, this can be thought
of as two separate phases.
And so this glucose
6-phosphate going to a pentose,
like ribose
5-phosphate, plus CO2,
that is referred to as the
oxidative pentose phosphate
pathway--
the oxidative pentose
phosphate pathway,
because it's using
oxidation of glucose carbon
to generate ribose
5-phosphate and NADPH.
Or, this swaps here
between 5-carbon sugars
and 6-carbon sugars and 3-carbon
sugars-- very similar to what
we saw in the Calvin cycle,
which is really interconverting
6-carbon and 3-carbon
sugars with 5-carbon sugars.
So that is referred to as
the nonoxidative pentose
phosphate pathway.
And it makes sense.
All those transketolase
and transaldolase reactions
that I just discussed
with you in great detail--
no electron movement,
no oxidation reduction,
nonoxidative PPP.
Similar to the
Calvin cycle, it's
converting pentoses with
trioses and hexoses.
So this should be very clear
now that this is actually
a really useful
things for cells,
because having this
pentose phosphate pathway
work in these two different
ways, the oxidative
than the nonoxidative, gives
cells a lot of flexibility
to make pentoses when they need
ribose to make nucleosides, as
well as NADPH when
they need NADPH to deal
with, say, oxidative stress.
Suppose you take a drug, causes
oxidative stress in your cells,
pentose phosphate
pathway can increase
as a way to make more NADPH.
So if a cell needs NADPH because
there's oxidative stress,
it can run the oxidative
pentose phosphate pathway
if it also needs to
make ribose great
it has a source of
pentoses to make ribose.
However, if it just needs
NADPH and not ribose, it
and then take those
ribose carbons,
re-enter them into glycolysis.
So running this shunt allows
you to get NADPH as well as ATP
while oxidizing glucose carbon.
However, if you need ribose
and you don't need NADPH,
well, forget the oxidative
PPP, just take sugars
from glycolysis and shunt
them over via the nonoxidative
PPP to make ribose.
And so you can run this
direction if you need NADPH.
And you can run this direction
if you just need ribose.
So this is great
because it gives cells
a lot of flexibility.
And so these two pathways,
really, can work together.
Or, they can work
separately depending
on what the cell
needs, and can really
be tuned in a way to allow
the cell to get both ribose
and NADPH and match
it as demands.
And so in a lot of ways,
it's probably better
to think of them as
two separate pathways--
a so-called oxidative PPP, which
is really glucose 6-phosphate
plus 2 NADP+, generating 2
NADPH plus pentose plus CO2.
And a nonoxidative
PPP, which is really
interconverting 3 pentoses
with 2 hexoses and 1 triose.
So 3 times 5 is 15 carbons.
2 times 6 is 12 carbons
plus 3 carbons, 15 carbons.
This reaction,
oxidative PPP, is only
going to be favorable
in one direction.
You would need a
separate pathway
if you're going to run it
the opposite direction.
That doesn't happen
in organisms.
So that's, under physiological
conditions, a one-way pathway.
You can only go one direction
through the oxidative PPP
in cells, whereas a
nonoxidative PPP is just
this interconversion of trioses
and hexoses with pentoses.
This is very reversible,
just like the Calvin cycle
would be very reversible.
And so while they can work
together as I described,
it's really useful to think
of them as separate pathways.
And so let's go
through each of them
separately so you can
see how they work.
So let's start first here with
the oxidative pentose phosphate
pathway.
So this here, it would be
alpha-glucose 6-phosphate.
So first step of the
oxidative pentose phosphate
pathway is we're
going to oxidize
the 1-carbon of glucose.
That's, of course, going
to have two electrons.
So if we oxidize that
carbon, something else
has to be reduced.
That hydride ion, those two
electrons can go to NADP+
to make NADPH--
a reaction that we've
now seen a million times.
That oxidizes the alcohol,
that carbon 1 to the ketone.
And that gives us this lactone--
very similar to what we
saw as the first step
in the epimerase reaction,
when we described that,
to give us this molecule,
6-phosphogluconolactone.
Now, so, in essence,
what this did, remember,
is it oxidized--
remember, this 1-carbon
was the aldehyde of
glucose, this now becomes,
on this lactose, it's
actually an acid.
And that becomes evident if
we break open this ring here
with water.
That causes this molecule,
6-phosphogluconate.
Oh, I forgot to mention
this first reaction here
is catalyzed by
this enzyme, G6PD--
glucose 6-phosphate
dehydrogenase.
Makes sense-- the oxidation
reduction reaction,
dehydrogenase, glucose
6-phosphate dehydrogenase.
Just as an aside for those
of you who are interested
in medical school, turns out
glucose 6-phosphate deficiency
in humans is actually a quite
common genetic disorder--
very common in
Mediterranean regions
because it is thought to have
evolved because it confers
some resistance to malaria.
And so having less G6PD
means you deal less well
with oxidative stress.
And as a result,
some foods and drugs
can cause increased
symptoms in those patients,
but also having that
means that the cells are
more resistant to
malaria infection
because the malaria
ends up killing the cell
before it can establish
an infection because it
causes some oxidative stress.
Back to the pathway--
so if we open up this
lactone, what we have here
is this molecule,
6-phosphor gluconate.
It's basically glucose
where the aldehyde has now
been oxidized to the acid.
That's how we generated NADPH.
The next step is we're
going to oxidize carbon 3.
So if we oxidize the
alcohol on carbon 3,
those electrons have
to go somewhere.
Put them on the net plus.
That gives us an edge.
This is catalyzed by 6
phophogluconate dehydrogenase--
generates an NADPH.
And what ends up being
generated is this intermediate.
If you look at
this intermediate,
this is a beta-keto acid.
So here's our acid that is
alpha beta to the ketone, so
a beta-keto acid.
Remember, decarboxylation of
beta-keto acids is favorable--
same track that we
saw before and the TCA
cycle and other places.
And so remember that
generates this enol.
And why it's so favorable
is because the enol prefers
to rearrange to the keto form.
And when we rearrange the
keto form, this, of course,
is the pentose
ribulose 5-phosphate.
And so ribose
5-phosphate, of course,
we saw in the Calvin cycle.
So we started with
phosphorylation at the one
position,
ribulose-1,5-bisphosphate.
So ribulose 5-phosphate
can be produced
by the oxidative pentose
phosphate pathway glucose
6-phosphate.
First oxidize the
1-carbon by G6PD.
That generates
6--phosphogluconate.
Oxidized the 3-carbon.
That allows favorable
decarboxylation
to generate another NADPH
and ribulose 5-phosphate.
Once you add that
ribulose 5-phosphate,
we can, of course,
use an isomerase.
And with an isomerase, we can
generate ribose 5-phosphate,
which is now
available to be sent
to do a nucleic acid synthesis.
Or, we can use an epimerase.
And if we use an epimerase, we
can change the stereochemistry
at this three position.
And that gives me
xylulose 5-phosphate,
which was the ketose donor and
acceptor for the transketolase,
transaldolase reactions that
were so useful for entering
the nonoxidative pentose
phosphate pathway or basically
some version of
the Calvin cycle.
And so we can get
ribose 5-phosphate,
xylulose 5-phosphate,
ribulose 5-phosphate
all as products of the
oxidative pentose phosphate
pathway, which will allow us to
either generate ribose as a way
to make nucleosides or have
carbon in the right form
that I can now run the oxidative
pentose phosphate pathway
and have it re-enter glycolysis.
Great.
So that's the oxidative
pentose phosphate pathway.
Now, let's discuss the
nonoxidative pentose phosphate
pathway, which just
like the Calvin cycle,
is interconversion of
3-carbon and 6-carbon sugars
with 5-carbon sugars.
Basically it's the
Calvin cycle, same idea--
transketolase, transaldolase.
Obviously, it evolved
from the Calvin cycle,
because photosynthesis
had to be first.
So let me first put it
in context, how it works.
And then we can draw
it in more detail.
So this here is glycolysis.
If I run the oxidative
pentose phosphate pathway,
I can generate two NADPHs as
well as a ribulose 5-phosphate.
That ribulose 5-phosphate can be
turned into ribose 5-phosphates
and xylulose 5-phosphates--
aldose and ketose acceptors.
I can then use these
5-carbon sugars.
If I do a
transketolase reaction,
I'll get a 3-carbon aldose
and a 7-carbon ketose--
remember transketolase
moves two carbons
from the ketose to an
aldose, giving you a shorter
aldose and a longer ketose.
Now, if I run a
transaldolase reaction,
I'll move three carbons.
That gives me a 6-carbon
ketose and a 4-carbon aldose.
If I run another
transketolase reaction
with this 4-carbon sugar
with this 5-carbon sugar,
I will then generate another
6-carbon ketose and a three
carbon aldose.
These six carbon are
fructose phosphate
and this 3-carbon aldose is
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate.
And I can re-enter glycolysis.
The stoichiometry works up
if I do this three times.
So 3 times 5 equals 15 carbons.
So three ribulose 5-phosphates
from the oxidative PPP.
If I turn them into one
ribose 5-phosphate and two
xylulose 5-phosphate, I can
allocate one here and one here.
These two can come
together to give me
one fructose 6-phosphate and
one erythrose 4-phosphate.
That erythrose 4-phosphate
can use the other xylulose
5-phosphate to give me
another fructose 6-phosphate
and the glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate.
So [INAUDIBLE] I have two
hexoses and one triose coming
from my three pentoses--
and so total here,
again, of 15 carbons.
And so like the
Calvin cycle, these
transketolase and transaldolase
reactions are all reversible.
And so if I don't want to
run the oxidative pentose
phosphate pathway, I can start
with fructose 6-phosphates and
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphates
from glycolysis
and run it this direction
to generate riboses
in order to make nucleosides.
Just to be explicit about
this, hopefully this all
makes sense after
the long discussion
we had of the Calvin cycle
and how these reactions work.
And you could work
this out yourself.
But I'll close today by just
showing this and how it works.
I'll actually show it in
the opposite direction.
I described it here
moving from products
of the oxidative PPP running
through the nonoxidative PPP
to re-enter glycolysis.
But I'm going to now draw it
for you, starting with products
of glycolysis, running
the nonoxidative PPP
in the other direction
to generate pentoses
just because this is
so reversible, but also
point out to you how this
whole thing can work.
So here is a glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate from glycolysis.
That's a aldose acceptor.
Here's a fructose
6-phosphate from glycolysis.
That can be a keto [INAUDIBLE].
And so if I run a
transketolase reaction--
so remember, transketolase--
transfer two carbons
from the ketose to the aldose.
What am I left with?
Well, I'm left with
a shorter aldose.
And this is a
erythrose 4-phosphate.
And I'm left with
a longer ketose.
There is a pentose
xylulose 5-phosphate.
Now I have my
erythrose 4-phosphate
and my fructose 6-phosphate.
So if I now carry out a
transaldolase reaction--
so I'm going to move
three carbons now
for my ketose donor,
fructose 6-phosphate,
to my aldose acceptor.
And so what do I end up with?
So I end up with a--
this becomes 3 carbons shorter,
so glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate.
Move the three carbons from the
ketose to the aldose acceptor.
Now I end up with
a longer ketose.
Now I have this 7-carbon
sedoheptulose 7-phosphate.
If I now, again, run a
transketolase reaction--
so two carbons here
transferred from the ketose
to the aldose, what
I end up with now
is a 5-carbon
xylulose 5-phosphate.
And so aldose becomes a
longer ketose by two carbons.
And our ketose becomes
a shorter aldose
by two carbons, which
is a ribose 5-phosphate.
I can now have two
xylulose 5-phosphates
and a ribose 5-phosphate.
I can take my
xylulose 5-phosphates
and carry out an
epimerase reaction.
If I carry out an epimerase
reaction, I, of course, get--
change the stereochemistry
at the three position
to get a ribulose 5-phosphate.
Or, I can carry out
an isomerase reaction
to take my ribose 5-phosphate
to ribulose 5-phosphate.
And so if you note
that I started
this time with
products of glycolysis,
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate,
fructose 6-phosphate,
did a series of transketolase
and transaldolase reactions,
ultimately to generate
two fructose 6-phosphates,
one glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate-- so
that's 6 plus 6 plus
3 equals 15 carbons.
I get three pentoses out,
a xylulose 5-phosphate,
a ribose 5-phosphate,
and a xylulose
5-phosphate, which I can then
use epimerase or isomerase
reactions to give me ribulose
5-phosphate, which, of course,
all could be shuttled
into ribose 5-phosphate,
giving me the flexibility
to start with products
of glycolysis and
net generate ribose
5-phosphate for
nucleoside synthesis.
If I run the oxidative
pentose phosphate pathway,
I end up with
ribulose 5-phosphates.
I can take those
ribulose 5-phosphates,
turn them into xylulose
5-phosphates and ribose
5-phosphates, run
the same series
of transketolase and
transaldolase reactions
in reverse and get
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphates and
fructose 6-phosphates.
Either direction, 15
carbons in, 15 carbons out,
can start with products
of the oxidative PPP
and put them back in glycolysis
or start with products
of glycolysis and
generate pentoses,
such as ribose 5-phosphate
for nucleoside synthesis,
giving cells a
lot of flexibility
to take carbohydrates
from glycolysis
and make pentoses
for nucleosides,
as well as have a way
to generate NADPH.
I know there's a lot of
carbons moving around
and a lot of swapping,
but hopefully
after today how it works
and why it works this way is
a little bit clearer
than if you just
sit down and try to
memorize these really
confusing pathways.
Next time we'll talk
about how one uses NADPH
as a source of reducing
power in all organisms
in order to synthesize
fatty acids.
Thanks.